a passé des centaines d'heures à recréer
le sud-ouest de Montréal sur cette
maquette qui occupe une petite pièce
dans son sous-sol passionné par les
traits miniatures mais aussi par les
vrais il souhaite la mise en place de
véritable réseau ferroviaire dédié aux
passagers c'est une barrassant au Canada
et aux Etats-Unis quand on voit la
serviette de train passager là c'est
vraiment d'une temps passé en
comparaison de la continent européenne
ou par exemple asiatique on est vraiment
vraiment derrière en juillet 2021 le
gouvernement fédéral a annoncé son
projet de train à grande fréquence pour
relier Toronto à Québec en passant
notamment par Ottawa Montréal et
Trois-Rivières
alors que le réseau actuel donne
priorité au train de marchandises on
prévoit la construction de nouvelles
voies réservées pour le transport des
passagers
ce projet là sera le plus grand projet
d'infrastructure de transport des
dernières décennies au Canada alors
qu'un très grandes fréquence circulerait
à 200 km à l'heure plusieurs voies
commencent à s'élever pour réclamer un
train à grande vitesse qui était une
vraie plutôt 300 km à l'heure ma
position c'est un TGV après le maire de
Québec Bruno marchand et le maire de
Laval Stéphane Boyer c'est au tour de
l'administration plante de se
positionner en faveur d'un TGV c'est des
gains de temps immenses le TGV puis dans
un contexte où justement je l'ai
mentionné on veut réduire nos émissions
de gaz à effet de serre il faut que les
alternatives qu'on propose soient
compétitive soit intéressante soit même
un gain pour les citoyens citoyennes par
rapport à ce qui existe déjà avec le
service actuel de VIA Rail le trajet
entre Montréal et Québec et d'une durée
moyenne de trois heures 24 avec un train
à grande fréquence des passagers
gagneraient au minimum 35 minutes mais
avec un train à grande vitesse
vous arriverez à destination en moins
d'une heure et demie pour la liaison
Montréal Toronto le trajet passerait
d'environ 5 heures à 4h10 en TGF mais ce
serait moins de trois heures en TGV et
puis se vend se vante fortement du fait
qu'on va avoir du Montréal Toronto
possiblement vers 4h20 mais si on
retourne à la période d'Expo 67 on avait
des services qui étaient déjà en trois
heures cinquante donc c'est on vise
d'être plus lent que ce qu'on avait il y
a 60 ans
selon lui il sera difficile de
convaincre les gens d'opter pour le
train si le gain de temps est trop
faible le TGF va vider les autobus mais
un TGV lui est capable de sortir les
automobilistes et les gens qui prennent
l'avion mais Ottawa jette un peu de
l'Est dans le cadre de l'appel d'offres
qui se ralentit on permettra aux
soumissionnaires de présenter des
projets dont la vitesse excèdent les 200
km à l'heure sur certaines portions du
trajet
hybrides si vous voulez en période
classique quand c'est
besoin et dans certaines portions du
trajet où l'alignement permet justement
d'augmenter la vitesse à ce moment-là
étudier la rentabilité de le faire le
coût du projet et l'enjeu principal pour
aller d'un TGF un TGV le matériel
roulant coûte quand même plus cher on va
plus à 200 on va à 300 km à l'heure mais
aussi c'est la voie ferrée doit être de
meilleure qualité on doit retirer tous
les passages de niveau c'est quand même
des centaines de passages à niveau qu'il
faut éliminer et aussi la voie ferrée
doit être clôturée sur son ancienne
longueur il estime que le TGF coûterait
environ 15 milliards de dollars alors
que la facture serait d'une soixantaine
de milliards pour un TGV un très à
grande vitesse nécessiterait la
construction de tunnels qui traverserait
Montréal et Toronto pour atteindre leur
centre-ville mais sans ces tunnel il
serait possible de construire un TGV
beaucoup moins cher autour de 25
milliards selon Pierre beriaud à
Montréal par exemple une gare pour être
construite dans le nord de la ville est
connecté au réseau express métropolitain
et l'option qui est actuellement sur la
table c'est possiblement qu'on va tout
simplement le service n'ira pas au
centre-ville de Montréal si on veut
contrôler les coûts il faut plutôt
déplacer la gare vers l'arrondissement
Saint-Laurent
ça vient la gare centrale en Mauricie on
attend le train avec impatience selon le
président de la Chambre de commerce de
Trois-Rivières les facilitera notamment
le recrutement de la main d'oeuvre dit
que ça fait des années qu'on milite pour
avoir un train à grande fréquence à
grande vitesse peu importe donc on sent
qu'il y a un effervescence importante
présentement dans notre région et on
croit que le train va être un acteur
extrêmement important dans ce
développement régional-là Alex Montagano
lui a une préférence claire un TGV c'est
le besoin service qui est efficace
pratique et très très rapide le nouveau
réseau ferroviaire sera inauguré dans
une dizaine d'années si tout va bien
reste à voir quelle vitesse le train
atteindra